Maybe you could tell us a little about the
the course of.
Of your application,
uh, until, uh,
not from your track record to this application.
Today, uh,
for the Europeans.
Uh.
So I'm an activist from,
perhaps a very long time ago.
In fact, this,
It still dates from the late 80's,
so it goes back very,
very, very far.
Uh,
it started with something actually,
that is, I was
high school girl in 1 high school called du monde d'Urville
in Toulon,
and in which,
uh,
we had 1 fraction uh.
Fascist,
it was the Saint-Cyrrhians,
so they were allowed anyway
to make parades with Nazi salute and Nazi chant,
uh.
At the back of the buildings,
and it was from.
To rename it enough,
uh. Well,
it was very famous this thing.
So it was in Toulon,
it was like this,
there were beatings at the exit of the
of the high school that was being held,
it was,
it was de rigueur,
eh,
it was 1 tradition,
it's like that,
but he fought each other much more,
so that was
much more fun,
that's it.
So it's started from there actually.
And I was an activist sympathizer with,
uh,
with coconuts,
the communist youth.
And then uh.
Now I left,
because
that I didn't really go into,
because it is 1 organization
highly hierarchical
and uh. It's,
here it is,
it's not,
it's not my Dada the hierarchy
and uh.
And then there you go.
So actually,
arrived, uh. I.
Came here,
uh.
Since the 2000s
and uh.
I've been militating on uh.
With attack,
with the cuckoos again,
with uh
the CGT,
around the European constitutional treaty,
and therefore for the rotation against the treaty
European constitutional.
And I boast,
actually that,
we got fifty-one for 100 on the chin side
thanks to me and 1 friend,
Mounir,
uh.
Who pulled like phadas
with 2 other attacking activists,
which is issoua,
who have come to help us.
But we managed to win,
uh,
in any case this struggle there.
And then I joined uh.
Some
anarchists in Nice.
Here it is,
1 small anarchist movement.
And from there,
uh. Well,
here we go
for Our Lady of slow zero-six,
uh uh des. Uh,
well,
there you go.
And lots of other little groups to uh on.
We have a lot of militancy.
In fact,
I worked as a night nurse
for years to be able to uh.
Uh,
militate during the day,
so there you go.
And uh.
So I joined France insoumise,
simply because,
Well, uh,
I wanted to join 1 movement that,
uh.
Wanted to take over
to fight uh.
Against destruction,
in fact,
uh.
Destruction uh.
Des. Des.
Social rights,
democratic rights by
capitalism
and uh, there you go,
and. And me, for me,
actually,
la France insoumise was at 1 1st step
uh.
In this struggle
and uh.
And I've been doing great since uh.
This year
and.
Every time it takes,
uh.
Uh.
That carry 1 application,
well
I say to myself, well,
why not?
I did legislative elections in two thousand seventeen seven,
the cantonals,
I needed it on my cash,
in fact,
someone was needed.
I was there with 2 communist comrades.
And now, well,
actually, I say,
well, why not
time, in fact,
the time of.
From, from
as of.
Campaign time is very useful to us actually,
on the territory,
to fight the battles of the territory which are
extremely serious.
We have the local mafia,
extremely active and destroys the social fabric
and, uh.
The democratic fabric in a way
extremely blatant.
We know when we live here,
that we are really
on the.
Uh.
We're the straight guy in neoliberalism
with 1 trend
very very very violent.
That's it, that's it,
for the little story.